♪
>> Rachel: FOX NEWS ALERT.
>> A BOMBSHELL NEW REPORT
SUGGESTING BIDEN'S BOTCHED EXITS
FROM AFGHANISTAN WAS EVEN WORSE
THAN WE THOUGHT.
ACCORDING TO THE "NEW YORK
TIMES," THE ISIS TERRORIST THAT
BIDEN SUPPOSEDLY DRONED IN
RETALIATION FOR THE AIRPORT
ATTACK IN KABUL WAS NOT AN ISIS
TERRORIST AFTER ALL.
HE WAS A U.S. AID WORKER.
IN HIS RUSH TO CLEAN UP THE
MESS, HIS INCOMPETENCE CAUSED AT
THE AIRPORT WERE 13 U.S. SERVICE
MEMBERS LOST THEIR LIVES, HE
AUTHORIZED A DRONE STRIKE ON THE
WRONG GUY AND LIKERY KILLED SELF
CHILDREN AS WELL VIDEO UNCOVERED
BY THE TIMES SHOWS THE AID
WORKER WAS NOT LOADING BOMBS HE
WAS LOADING BOTTLES OF WATER.
JOINING ME NOW ARE TWO
AFGHANISTAN WAR VETS.
MY FELLOW "FOX & FRIENDS
WEEKEND" CO-HOST PETE HEGSETH
AND SEAN PARNELL RETIRED ARMY
INFANTRY CAPTAIN.
PETE, WE WERE ON THE AIR WHEN
THAT DRONE STRIKE OCCURRED WE
THOUGHT MAYBE HE IS FINALLY
GETTING SOMETHING RIGHT HERE BUT
WE WERE WRONG.
YOUR REACTION?
>> IT APPEARS WE MAY BE.
FIRST OF ALL, RACHEL, I'M ALWAYS
SKEPTICAL OF THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" I'M ALWAYS SKEPTICAL OF
INTERNATIONAL JOURNALISTS GIVING
ACCESS THAT THE TALIBAN
CONTROLLED.
YOU DON'T HAVE WITHOUT APPROVAL
OF THE TALIBAN.
EVEN IF IT'S JOE BIDEN THEY ARE
TRYING TO MAKE AMERICA LOOK BAD
A NUMBER ONE.
IF THIS REPORT SOMETHING CORRECT
THEN, INDEED, EVERYTHING YOU ARE
SAYING IS CORRECT, WHICH IS IN
THEIR HASTE TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE
THEY ARE DOING SOMETHING THEY
PUSHED AND PUSHED AND PUSHED AND
POTENTIALLY KILLED AN AID WORKER
WHO WAS WORKING ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED STATES WHICH LEADS TO THE
FACT THAT I HAVE ZERO CONFIDENCE
IN JOE BIDEN AS A
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF, ESPECIALLY
CONSIDERING THE FACT THAT WE HAD
THREAT REPORTING ON THE AIRPORT
AT THE ABBEY GATE IN THE TIME
PERIOD IN WHICH OUR MARINES WERE
STILL ALLOWED GATHER THE WAY
THAT THEY DID.
HONOR IS PARNELL KNOWS AS WELL
AS ANYBODY IF YOU HAVE AN ACTIVE
THREAT GO ON THE OFFENSE AND
CREATE A PERIMETER, CHANGE THE
DYNAMIC OR REFORTIFY YOUR
POSITION.
AND THEY DID NEITHER.
SO THIS IS A CASCADING SET OF
DECISIONS BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND NOW THIS
REPORT IS TRUE, TRAGICALLY, IN
THEIR DESIRE TO MAKE THEMSELVES
LOOK GOOD, THEY DIDN'T IMPROVE
THE SECURITY SITUATION AT ALL
AND THE WRONG PEOPLE ARE DEAD.
>> Rachel: YEAH, IT'S REALLY
TRAGIC.
SEAN, I WANT TO PLAY THIS CLIP
IF I COULD HAVE OUR DEFENSE
SECRETARY WHO IS NOW CONCERNED
THAT WE ARE GOING TO HAVE MORE
TERRORISM NOT LESS FOLLOWING
THIS WITHDRAWAL.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THE WHOLE COMMUNITY IS KIND
OF WATCHING TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS
AND WHETHER OR NOT AL-QAEDA HAS
THE ABILITY TO REGENERATE IN
AFGHANISTAN.
THE NATURE OF AL-QAEDA AND
ISIS-K IS YOU KNOW, THEY WILL
ALWAYS ATTEMPT AT THE FIND SPACE
TO GROW AND REGENERATE WHETHER
IT'S THERE OR WHETHER IT'S IN
SOMALIA OR ANY OTHER UNGOVERNED
SPACE.
>> Rachel: SEAN, HOW MUCH OF
THIS INCREASE IN TERRORISM THAT
WE ARE NOW HEARING NOT JUST
AUSTIN TALK ABOUT BUT ALSO
GENERAL MILLEY AND I DON'T KNOW
OF THIS IS CYA BUT WE ARE SEEING
THERE IS AN INCREASE NOW.
IS IT WORST?
ARE WE IN A WORST POSITION TODAY
ON THE EVE OF THE 20TH
ANNIVERSARY OF 9/11 THAN WE WERE
MAYBE EVEN WHEN THIS WHOLE THING
STARTED?
MAGICALLY I THINK THAT WE ARE.
YOU CAN LAY OUTLINE OF THIS AT
JOE BIDEN'S FEET.
HE BASICALLY, IN A PART OF THIS
TRAGIC WITHDRAWAL IN
AFGHANISTAN, HE BASICALLY
CONTROL -- HE BASICALLY
INSTALLED A TERRORIST SUPER
STATE IN AFGHANISTAN.
SO, AS PART OF THE TALIBAN
INTERIM GOVERNMENT IS A GUY NAME
SIRAJ HACK HACK CAN ANY.
HE HAS A JOE BIDEN IS OPENLY
NEGOTIATING WITH ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE THE TALIBAN WITH HEKMATI OR
WITH THE HAQQANI NETWORK.
AIDING AND ABETTING TERRORIST
GROUPS ON THE EVE OF 9/11.
RACHEL, IF THAT IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT IS RESIGNATION WORTHY.
IF THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
IMPEACHMENT WORTHY, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT ELSE.
I THINK UNFORTUNATELY OUR WORLD
IS FAR -- IS A FAR MORE
DANGEROUS PLACE NOW, NOT BECAUSE
WE LEFT AFGHANISTAN, BUT BECAUSE
OF THE WAY WE LEFT AFGHANISTAN.
AND THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
BASICALLY A GERIATRIC FOREIGN
POLICY DISASTER AS OUR
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
AND SO, YES, THE WORLD IS MORE
DANGEROUS LEADING INTO THE 20TH
ANNIVERSARY OF SEPTEMBER 11TH.
>> Rachel: PETE, THE HUMILIATING
WAY IN WHICH WE LEFT AFGHANISTAN
AND IT WAS HUMILIATING.
HOW MUCH MORE PAINFUL IS 9/11,
IS THIS 20TH ANNIVERSARY?
HOW MUCH MORE PAINFUL IS BIDEN
MAKING IT FOR AMERICANS?
>> Pete: VERY MUCH SO SINCE HE
ATTEMPTED TO SET THE DATE ON
9/11 AND REELINGIZED THAT WAS A
TERRIBLE IDEA.
INSTEAD MOVED IT FORWARD AND
EXACERBATED THE PROBLEM.
WE ARE GOING TO BE LIVE ON THE
AIR WITH "FOX & FRIENDS."
I'M DOING MY BEST TO SEPARATE
THE ABSOLUTE SHEAR INCOMPETENCE
OF WHAT BIDEN HAS UNRAVELED IN
AFGHANISTAN WHICH SEAN SAID SO
WELL FROM THE RECOGNITION THAT
THE HEROES DESERVE FOR THIS DAY
20 YEARS LATER AND THE DESPERATE
PLEA THAT WE NOT FORGET AND THE
DESPERATE PLEA THAT WE NOT TAKE
OUR EYE OFF THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE RADICAL ISLAMIST STILL TO
THIS DAY THAT SEEK OUR
DESTRUCTION THAT NOW HAVE A MEGA
TERRORIST STATE IN AFGHANISTAN.
AND ULTIMATELY IF WE FORGET WHAT
THEIR GOALS ARE WHICH IS THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE WEST, WE WILL
BE INCAPABLE IN FUTURE
GENERATIONS OF ADDRESSING IT NOT
TO MENTION THREATS LIKE THE
COMMUNIST CHINESE.
JOE BIDEN HAS MADE IT IMMINENTLY
WORST.
SEAN IS TOTALLY RIGHT.
TOMORROW IS A DAY TO REMEMBER SO
WE HAVE THE ABILITY, MAYBE, SORT
OF, POSSIBLY, TO MUSTER A
RESPONSE SHOULD WE NEED TO WHICH
LOOKS MORE LIKELY IN THE FUTUR